je vous parle depuis la suisse où je
suis né sur une petit
la montagne dans une communauté paysanne
pas toujours eu unis au quotidien mais
qui s'unissaient autour de travaux
communs face à la rivière à dompter
reconstruire des ponts et aussi pour
faire du théâtre ensemble pour chanter
et dans des moments de deuil et ce monde
protégé pour moi d'une certaine manière
c'est trouver fissuré au moment où j'ai
dû continuer ma scolarité dans la
station touristique à côté s'appelle
jade et où j'ai fait l'expérience que on
nous appelait les enfants les personnes
qui venaient depuis derrière la lune et
[Musique]
c'est gégé parfois été bagarreur pour
essayer de me défendre et j'ai fait
l'expérience que quand on sent que d'où
on vient
ce qu'on est ou n'est pas n'est pas
forcément respectée compris ça devient
difficile d'apprendre les choses se
mélangent dans notre tête mais aussi ça
devient difficile d'apporter ce qu'on a
en nous les couleurs caché que toute
personne a en elle et c'est peut-être ça
qui a fait que je suis devenu enseignant
mais j'ai gardé tout un métier que j'ai
beaucoup aimé mais j'ai gardé une sorte
intranquillité en moi et c'est en 1972
que j'ai fait la connaissance de deux du
mouvement atd agir tous pour la dignité
car monde et je me suis engagé comme
volontaire permanent alors vous parlant
depuis la suisse je me demande bien
quelle représentation vous avez de ce
pays et est peut-être bien sûr le
chocolat le fromage les montres mais
plus grave beaucoup plus grave
le secret bancaire où certains peut-être
vont dire oui mais chez vous vous
targuez de démocratie et les femmes on
le droit de votre très tard dans votre
histoire ou d'autres qui diront vous dit
vous êtes un pays accueillant mais il
faut attendre la troisième génération
pour pouvoir devenir suisse et mais je
me demande est ce que vous savez que
c'est un pays qui a une longue et
profonde histoire de pauvreté de misère
et qu'aujourd'hui dans ce même pays qui
peut être internationalement plutôt
l'image d'avoir su venir à bout de la
pauvreté dans ce pays
près de 10% de la population se trouve
dans une situation de pauvreté est au
coeur de cette histoire de mon pays à se
dire terrifiant celui qui ne travaille
pas il ne mangera fin et aussi dans
cette histoire au nom de la sécurité
publique dans les villages dans les
tours d'église dans les tours délit
d'église il y avait des docks 5 ont
sonné quand il y avait des groupes de
personnes des femmes des hommes des
familles des enfants en recherche de
survie de mendier chercher un petit
travail mais aussi dans ce même pays
face à ces gens qui cherchent à survivre
ont distribué dans les communes des
fusils pour abattre les gens si
nécessaire et puis petit à petit cette
histoire de la pauvreté s'est focalisée
autour d'un d'une sorte de contrôler une
prise de contrôle sur les pauvres autour
des pauvres et une une mesure
législative très très fort et très
humiliants pour les pauvres dans mon
pays c'était la possibilité de d'être
mis sous tutelle
ça veut dire on peut vous enlever votre
signature
on peut vous vous n'avez plus le droit
de voter dans un pays pourtant qui se
dit démocratique
on peut vous saisir tout ce que vous
avez pu gagner et vous êtes privé de
votre responsabilité envers vous même
envers vos enfants envers votre famille
et puis dans cette évolution dans mon
pays face à la peau
arrêtez c'est développer un courant
psychiatrique
il ya eu des chercheurs qui ont établi
qu'ils ont osé dire ouvertement la
pauvreté en fait c'est une maladie
mentale et vous vous imaginez les
conséquences graves ça veut dire des
personnes des jeunes des adultes des
femmes révoltées de vivre des injustices
dans un contexte de pauvreté on les
considérait leur attitude comme malade
mental et il se trouvait enfermée dans
des cliniques psychiatriques et au corps
de tous à l'histoire des placements
extra familiaux des enfants très tôt et
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui on
continue à enlever à des familles qui se
trouvent en situation de pauvreté leurs
enfants en disant vous êtes des parents
ou n'êtes pas capables d'offrir une
sécurité à vos enfants
alors ce sont des parents qui vivent des
injustices dans tout les domaines du
travail du logement de la santé de de la
participation à la culture et ses
enfants ont été placés dans des
institutions chez des paysans dans des
dans des centres de redressement dans
des cliniques psychiatriques et même
dans des prisons et ses enfants à
travers le temps ont été abusés mal
traitée sous alimentés violet et
certains se sont donné la mort je pense
un militant dates et des cars monde en
suisse alain meylan il raconte comment
il devait se lever à 5 heures du matin
pour travailler dans l'écurie où il
était placé chez des paysans et à la
sortie de l'école il disait le paysan
nous attendait à six sur sa petite
mobylette avec un fouet dans la main et
il le lancer au dessus de nos têtes et
nous gamins en cours et bien sûr de peur
de prendre des coups mais beaucoup plus
profondément de 2,7 de sentir les
regards des gens du village qui voyait
ça et qui d'une certaine manière
détourné la tête et il disait la nuit on
nous entende et pleurait mais personne
les voisins ne réagissait pas ça
semblait être normal est ainsi dans mon
pays il ya eu une évolution ou peu
petit à petit les personnes en situation
de pauvreté ont été rendues invisibles
de plus en plus invisibles enfermés dans
des institutions mais aussi enfermé dans
des analyses de de gens de problèmes de
personnes à sociale etc et surtout le
plus grave
enfermé dans un silence très très
profond et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
dans mon pays dans les cas l'école ou à
l'université
on ne parle pas cette histoire elle est
pas connue et les parents saignée parce
que à travers tout le temps les
personnes dans les situations les plus
pauvres dans mon pays n'ont pas eu la
possibilité de la prise de parole ils
apparaissent dans l'histoire des autres
dans l'analyse des autres dans le regard
des autres
mais mon pays se trouvent privés de
l'histoire ça veut dire du regard de la
compréhension de ce qu'ils ont vécu dans
mon pays les injustices les plus
profondes et ça c'est grave et sas a
deux conséquences très graves
ici dans ce pays la première c'est que
nier jusqu'à nier l'existence d'une
réalité ça amène et jean-marc un
militant aussi daté des carmes andy se
rendent compte qu'on n'est pas rare qu
dans notre existence même ça nous amène
à nous à penser qu'on est coupable
d'avoir était né dans ce monde là donc
c'est un processus qui empêche les gens
de comprendre d'où ils viennent de bâtir
leur identité de comprendre l'origine
entité de à travers leur identité aussi
pouvoir l'a transformé la partager avec
d'autres de lutte et à partir de là pour
la participation
la dignité est aussi ce qui les
conséquences graves c'est nier une
réalité historique et aujourd'hui c'est
en même temps juillet nier ne pas
reconnaître ne pas voir les
connaissances que les personnes qui
vivent ces réalités peuvent apprendre et
nelly schenker
une militante du mouvement atd quart
monde et le dit c'est vrai on est
souvent critiquée pour pour ce conte ce
qu'on le fait qu'on retourne vers ceux
qui sont pas là mais en fait c'est
indispensable parce que ceux qui ne sont
pas là qui ne partagent pas kiki qui en
fait ils ont les connaissances les plus
importantes de 2,2 qu'est ce qu'il faut
pour créer des conditions de
participation de tous épi nier cette
existence
ça veut dire aussi un pays se prive de
sa possibilité de réfléchir jusqu'où en
fait on est déjà allé dans une mise en
place de justice et d'éthique tpour pour
tout le monde
une recherche d'égal dignité une mise en
oeuvre de l'ensemble des droits humains
donc voilà je vous parle de ce pays
parce que c'est mon pays c'est il m'a
forgé
mais dans le mouvement atd quart monde
aussi à travers mon engagement
j'ai découvert et appris bien sûr comme
vous et vous le savez que la grande
pauvreté la pauvreté est une réalité
mondiale et atd quart monde y est
engagée dans une trentaine de pays avec
un réseau de solidarité de partage
d'expériences a par exemple énormément
bataille et lorsqu'il ya eu là la
discussion autour de l'agenda 2030 et la
formulation de ses objectifs du
développement durable
le mouvement a bossé beaucoup investi
pour essayer avec d'autres organisations
de gagner cet objectif ne laisser
personne de côté
parce que si on commence à laisser des
gens de côté voilà on s'égare de d'une
recherche de deux légal dignité entre
nous deux de la participation et c'était
une victoire que dans ses objectifs
vous connaissez peut-être qu'ils sont
assez forts et nos pays les ont signés
la suisse aussi les a signés il ya
maintenant cet objectif ne laisser
personne de côté
mais ça veut dire quoi au juste
vous connaissez peut-être cette
définition la pauvreté est très pauvre
c'est vivre avec un dos leurs 25 pour
site de centimes par jour
c'est beaucoup trop trop rétrécissent
ans et c'est un anglo passe a dit pas le
la complexité l'interdît nationalité de
ce que vivent les gens qui se trouvent
dans la pauvreté
et c'est pour ça que le mouvement s'est
mis dans une recherche avec l'unique
l'université d'oxford pour dire il faut
qu'on travaille
elles sont on appelait ça les dimensions
cachées de la propreté
c'est un projet qui s'est déroulé ces
dernières années au bangladesh en
bolivie en tanzanie en france en
angleterre aux etats-unis où des groupes
de cercles aux chercheurs avec des
universitaires des professionnels mais
aussi des personnes en situation de
grande pauvreté se sont demandés mais
qu'elles sont quelles sont les
dimensions qui font la réalité de la
grande pauvreté et à la fin il ya eu un
séminaire où les acteurs de cette
recherche ont mis leurs réflexions leurs
travaux en commun et savez vous ce qui
est sorti comme dimension commune alors
que des réalités sont très différentes
de du bangladesh à la france par exemple
c'est que lorsqu'on se trouve dans une
situation de pauvreté
on est privé du pouvoir du pouvoir agir
et aux acteurs de cette étude a dit est
très pauvre
c'est faire partie d'un système qui vous
fait attendre indéfiniment dans un état
de peur d'incertitude et d'impuissance
un deuxième point commun de deux des dix
mentions de cachets de la pauvreté
c'était que les acteurs ont dit la
souffrance de ceux qui sont dans la
pauvreté n'est ni connu ni reconnu ni
souvent et plus grave les efforts des
pauvres qu'ils entreprennent pour non
seulement pour survivre mais pour aider
à bâtir une justice changer les pays
c'est très souvent ignorée au sein de
nos pays et 7
cette impulsion cette recherche
avec cette question dû être dépossédé du
pouvoir d'agir
comment on retourne ça pour le mouvement
ça c'est une question depuis son
existence on pourrait dire cette
question et dans les adn dates et des
carmes en son fondateur
il est né dans la grande pauvreté et ils
en voulaient pas d'un an +22 de dette
sociale de 2-2-2 de soutien de mesures
spécifiques de projets pour les pauvres
il disait il faut obliger nos pays à
changer ensemble a osé d'éviter
politique globale cohérente et
prospective ancré dans l'ensemble des
droits humains et surtout guidés par cet
enjeu d'une égale dignité entre les ans
entre tout le monde et ce défi cette
orientation par exemple juste pour vous
donner quelques exemples a amené le
mouvement a développé par exemple une
action comme le croisement des savoirs
dans le croisement des savoirs il s'agit
d'amener trois sources de connaissance
dans un dialogue dans un croisement
celui des universités des universitaires
ni celui des professionnels et celui des
personnes qui vivent qui ont
l'expérience de la grande pauvreté
maîtresse et savoir en dialogue mettre
ensemble analysé ensemble et faire des
propositions ensemble pour opérer des
propositions d'actions qui qui sont
enrichis de ces trois sources fontaines
de connaissances et vérifie aussi par
ses trois sources
aucune de ces sources de connaissance
peut remplacer les autres ses ailes sont
complémentaires et en suisse
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle depuis
deux ans le gouvernement fédéral finance
une une recherche dans ce sens-là du
croisement des savoirs ou des acteurs
universitaires des militants qui ont
l'expérience de la grande pauvreté et
des professionnels des juges des des
enseignants des médecins des infirmières
etc mettent ensemble leurs connaissances
et leurs questions pour dire qu est ce
qu il faut qu'on change aujourd'hui dans
les institutions dans un pays comme la
suisse pour que l'histoire qu'on a
connus ne se répète pas mais quand je
vous dis ça je devrais vous parler d'un
projet qui a lieu en france qui est très
passionnant qui est territoire sert aux
chômeurs et le temps et pain pour vous
dire l'histoire de ce projet nini a
exactement son contenu mais vous je vous
invite vraiment alesis sur son site pour
voir parce que c'est là une véritable
innovation qui dit le chômage
de toute façon le chemin dans la longue
durée est inacceptable il faut retourner
tout cet argent dans des projets ou des
personnes qui connaissent le long
travail et des personnes qui ont des
diplômes créé ensemble des innovations
des petites entreprises qui sont pas
d'insertion qui sont des projets pilotes
au niveau d'une économie solidaire
donc ça c'est quelque chose aussi je
vous ai parlé de l'importance de
l'histoire
le mouvement a créé un centre de
recherche et de mémoire pour essayer de
ramasser toutes les petites briques qui
existe dans les pays des photos des
textes des dires des gens
pour bâtir cette histoire qui reste
quand même pour beaucoup dans notre
humanité
un trou noir et qui doit être enrichi
aujourd'hui par les gens eux mêmes
au moins aujourd'hui que ceux qui vivent
ces injustices puisse contribuer à
écrire cette histoire et c'est un centre
qu' il est temps en cours de
reconnaissance comme un apport à
l'histoire de l'humanité par l'unesco
mais le mouvement ne peut pas demander
aux autres d'agir en partenariat avec
ceux qui visent la pauvreté qui vivent
la pauvreté si nous mêmes on se
questionne pas constamment à ce niveau
là et bien sûr parfois nous faisons des
erreurs parfois nous arrivons pas à
rendre la participation vraiment de
possibles de personnes qui sont dans des
situations très extrême de survie et
qu'il faut beaucoup de temps qu'il faut
retourner qu'il faut faut inventer pour
que par la confiance qui se créé leur
parti participation devient possible
mais on a au moins on a appris que dans
un mouvement comme le nôtre il nous faut
une gouvernance à l'horizontale ça veut
dire il faut on a besoin d'une
gouvernance qui soutient les activistes
les militants ceux qui sont engagés dans
notre mouvement à la fois très
localement dans un contexte historique
social culturel et c'est très spécifique
où on peut pas dire on a un modèle de
participation allons-y tout est à
inventer avec les gens sur place
mais au même temps il faut permettre que
ces acteurs ou niveau local puissent
aussi été acteurs au niveau
international on viendra pas la boue de
la pauvreté sans des grands actions
internationales avec l'agenda de de 2030
et donc de permettre à ce que ce qui
fait que les gens gagnent en
connaissances en expérience en savoir
localement dans des pays puissent se
retrouver s'enrichir au niveau
international pour évaluer pour
programmer pour relever des défis
ensemble
et je peux vous dire c'est une bagarre
que dès que des experts de ceci ou de
cela de l'économie ou voilà puissent
voyager personnes mais sans en question
que des pauvres qu'ils ne veulent pas
juste fuir le pays mais qui sont des
militants et qui veulent se retrouver
avec d'autres dans des sessions
internationales puissent avoir un visa
je vous dis ça reste un sacré combat est
parfois très dur pour des gens qui
avaient préparé le rapport et on leur
dit désolé refus refus de visa donc on
va apprendre à rester vigilants et
combatifs
aujourd'hui et je veux terminer par là
on se trouve avec cette pandémie très
difficile pour tous et atd quart monde
on se demande qu'est ce que nous-mêmes
comme mouvement mais aussi avec les
autres on a appris deux populations de
personnes qui depuis toujours se
trouvent dans des dents dans des
situations de de maladie de deux
familles de deux situations de guerre de
la misère la pauvreté qui est en elle
même une sorte de crise permanente
qu'avons nous appris ensemble qu'on peut
aujourd'hui investir pour faire face à
ce qu vide 19 et en disant ça je pense
un philosophe chinois sheng wang c'est
un ami du du mouvement et il nous disait
ceci ya pas très longtemps
il disait prendre les plus pauvres comme
miroir dans chacun de nos pays comme
repère de nos sincérité de penser et de
nous engager et d'agir est un chemin qui
appartient à l'histoire de la lutte de
l'humanité pour la dignité et pis il
continue et constitue une possibilité de
rencontre entre des sival civilisation à
hauteur des yeux et pour terminer je
voudrais vous dire que jeunes
volontaires permanents des télécommandes
je me disais voilà gène tu tu appuies
apprendre un métier et une certaine
liberté tu vas tu as investir avec
pour un temps je ne savais pas que ça
pouvait durer aussi longtemps avec des
des personnes qui n'ont pas eu ses
chances et c'était comme si je pouvais
leur apporter ma liberté comme moi
j'étais vraiment libre et que ne l'était
pas et petit à petit avec d'autres j'ai
compris que cette histoire de la liberté
est beaucoup plus profonde est que
personne peut prétendre qu'ils se
libèrent sol c'est très prétentieux
tout le monde a besoin à un moment donné
de quelqu'un qui croit dans ce qu'on
cherche qui aussi est un ami ou une ami
et nous reprendre on ne peut pas
quelques spasmes mais certainement aussi
ceux qui sont dans la pauvreté ils ont
besoin d'autres et aussi personne va
libérer seuls les autres c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait ensemble et dans ce
sens là j'ai découvert à travers mon
engagement dans le mouvement qu'en fait
ceux qui sont dans la pauvreté ils nous
proposent un projet de libération ça
veut dire de de grandir en liberté
ensemble et c'est quelque chose de très
puissant ça ouvre sa ans fermes passées
et pour moi je fais le lien avec notre
humanité qui est qui est vraiment marqué
forgé par toutes ces combats de
recherche de liberté à travers le refus
de l' esclavage à travers le refus de la
domination des hommes sur les femmes etc
etc et je porte en moi cette conviction
que ceux qui sont dans la pauvreté dans
nos pays de france à travers le monde
jusqu'en suisse en fait et c'est aussi
ils sont aussi dans un apport de si on
s'engage ensemble si on ose sauter
ensemble à l'eau pour apprendre à nager
ou c'est un apport à l'humanité de
gagner de grandir en liberté qui est la
clé pour que chacun puisse offrir les
couleurs à l'intérieur les plus
précieuses